[Musique]
pendant que les malheureux shadoks
essaie en vain de faire partir leurs
fusées à la main les jb finissent
d'aménager la leur
la fusée jbe comportez pas mal d'états
ge d'abord un premier étage propulseur
contenant le combustible jbe d'une
puissance infinie le cosmo goal 999
aux étages supérieurs ont trouvé une
piscine chauffée entièrement aménagé
une salle de jeux avec balançoires
patins à roulettes jeu de dominos et
autres appareillages hautement
perfectionnées indispensable pour
survivre sur l'écorcé terrestre
un étage carnaval avec manèges montagnes
russes et autres instruments de
navigation indispensable pour la même
raison un étage campagne avec des fleurs
des arbres des petits ruisseaux et des
jardins potagers ou les gibiers cultiver
des légumes est nécessaire pour subvenir
à leurs besoins techniques moteur
électrique et ionique microphone en
grappe gyroscope possible de télévision
et dans les vergers
il poussait d antenne radar des gôniots
m et des radiotélescopes tous ces
instruments la donner et des graines que
l'on récoltait et quand on voulait en
fabriquer il suffisait de les semer dans
des endroits adéquats
c'est dire qu'avec seulement les jbe
pourrait faire de la terre une planète
très confortable
[Musique]
e